I was gonna ask Tiff to I was gonna lay
on the sidewalk next to her like her
sitting there and with my face like this
and I was gonna go Tiff act like I'm a
homeless guy and that you want to bring
me home to like help me out
I was gonna be like just try to convince
him that like we should help him he
seems like a good guy and I was just
gonna sit like this
[Music]
welcome back to another Nick based
episode of careful boys about how funny
Nick is hilarious yeah yeah first of all
uh thank you guys again for all your
comments on every video where you point
out how funny Nick is I feel like you
guys are making fun of me and just
getting everyone to say that no no
there's a running thing where like
people are trying to appreciate his
humor and how funny he's gotten but he's
kind of like cracked out of his shell
you know like surprise appreciate it
yeah I Nick you inspire me to to be like
you one day you know I'm kind of the
giggler right now so I just wanna
try to absorb your methods of being just
this comedy hero see how she makes fun
of me should we go around the room and
compliment him real quick yeah yeah I
got a piece of almond stuck in my throat
and I thought I was in the cop so that's
why I was making those faces you were a
passion project when you first came here
I was like Nick is like he's so not
funny I don't know how the [__] he's
ever gonna last with us [__] useless
guy I liked watching him squirm because
every time we gave him compliments
um he just couldn't take it so we just
hired him for that sole reason only
nothing else you got any compliments for
him having cold met him today like
what's nah dude let's not do this how
ears you know I thought we're gonna talk
about how you thank you I appreciate it
but we'll get there okay we're good but
years yeah number
yeah yeah I just met him today yeah
number two what's your number two thing
they're so suckable huh yeah
dude I'll let you dude if you want
do you think they're hard or soft what
do you think something's crunchy it
looks crunchy it's pretty crunchy like a
cauliflower that's why they call it
cauliflower you want to put it to the
tester my ears kind of like little
gyoza's like a little dumpling they do
look like specifically it's not look at
Din Tai fun on his ear dude not soup
dumplings does that even hurt I'm
[__] squeezing the [__] out of here
but somebody somebody Joe I'm squeezing
the [__] out of them okay dude relax
okay
whoa whoa I don't know how much longer
you can squeeze it my thumb's white no
it doesn't hurt okay dude I thought it
was filled with pot I gotta buff his arm
is you know how buff this hand is
they're not like balloons and then he
pushes the a pus back into your brain
they get hard this one's hard this one's
hard so obviously you know that Nick uh
he he's a fighter he also does a lot of
training from he's like changed people
he's the most manliest man here I'm not
the dude I'm not he can [__] all of us
up hell yeah yeah kill he can kill us he
just every minute every minute he just
chooses yeah but he's so friendly he's
so nice yeah so I've had this running
joke
um like I want to say Nick's included
but it's really just for me I try to
figure out where he lives
so like I'll just send him like this is
where both of them and like I've been
talking to him here and there like in
between takes trying to get hints and he
doesn't know that's why I'm talking to
him and uh I'll just be like oh man I
love this restaurant he'll go oh you
know I live right by that and I'll just
go okay and I'll make a note so one day
I was in the area that I believed he
lived around right I went to
um I went to a Michael's craft shop that
I thought was nearby him and I was like
you know I'm gonna do a little bit of
scouting so yeah almost there yeah I was
with smack and I was like hey can you
take a photo of me in front of all the
houses in this area and I'm just gonna
send him to him just to like and then
I'm gonna gauge his reaction and see if
I've got his house I narrowed it down to
one street I'm like I know he lives on
this street he's never even told me the
street name I know he lives what makes
you feel like like that's the street
process of elimination and I know that
he's not willing to I know he's not
willing to his attitude tells me he's
not willing to walk very far to some
things
can I guess one thing yeah can I guess
because I don't know where you live
either yeah can I can I guess if if I if
this is your house yeah
if I walked out over here here's a
street that connects to a Main Street on
this side
potentially yeah
[Music]
the clues that I gather is every time he
has ACT outs there's a specific way he
explains it yeah and in the acting it
seems like I can see the room we live on
a busy street and then yeah yeah so from
his Actos I'm like I think he's either
the house on the corner or three or
within five houses right from the street
and then this is the busy side not this
because of the way you guys are [__]
internet because the way he acts out his
sister exactly and especially when he
first told the story about the homeless
guy that was pissing on his stoop or
whatever I'm like that only happens
usually if you're in the vicinity of
like a main road yeah so like I was I
was like doing a photo shoot around
that's right like here's one and then I
I sent I like took that one and then
smacks like dude these people are gonna
think you're gonna rob their houses
because we're going door to door and I
was like I'm not gonna collect as many
as possible while we're in the middle of
doing this
we see [__] Nick walk into a shop I'm
not gonna say where because I want
everyone to know like a restaurant a
store it's a it's an Eatery
that's Nick right there she goes I could
see the back of his head and I can see
his ears that's Nick and then uh so then
we filmed this video literally within
seconds of seeing him
I I can't tell you how ridiculous all
right
I have a pretty good feeling that he's
nearby
you're getting a boba dude
I was getting acai bowl at nine o'clock
was Tiff sitting outside
[Laughter]
oh that's good
I couldn't believe it dude I couldn't it
was so not in my I was so worried about
getting this acai Bowl I was like
focused on like okay he's gonna put on
the bag that's what I was thinking about
and then all I hear is this guy talking
getting closer to me and then say my
name and I'm like what the [__] I didn't
see his beard and I'm like that's
[__] Ryan has a future in like a
private investigation how long were you
searching for this is this is what
really blew my mind and this is when I
was like I have to move somewhere else
no I think uh it was only I only got
like five photos done so maybe like 10
minutes smack was like it took us four
minutes to find you damn you guys are
good you guys are too good I mean it's
just my luck you were outside your house
and that was okay that usually
I'm at the gym all night I took the
night off so I could go take the dogs
for a walk around like the area yeah and
we went for like an extra long walk and
we're like Hey we're about to go home
and we're like let's go around again so
we went around again and then I was like
you know what I think I want a boat I
wanna I Wanna Get outside your balls wow
it was meant to be did you follow him
home no I I wanna I I don't want to lose
a mystery I think I mean you should have
been like all right see you later and
then just kind of like we're moving dude
so usually you wouldn't even have been
there because you would have been
training or something yeah I would have
been at the gym or I would just like one
thing I was gonna try the gym uh after
that if I didn't what if intuitively you
knew he was coming you're like oh I have
to see him okay I told him that could be
it because before we started the walk I
knew if we're gonna go on a walk there's
a chance I'm Gonna Wanna grab something
to eat that's like not that good for me
to eat so I was like I'm not gonna do
that that's what I said and then like
last five minutes I was like I'm gonna
do it
I'm gonna do it but I was like I'm gonna
go to acai ball I was like that'd be
that'd be healthy not really but the
spirits were guiding you dude I trusted
my intuition they're like go get the
acai Ryan and smack and we got to hang
out with them for 10 minutes and they're
like all right we gotta leave we gotta
go build a roller rink and I'm like all
right sounds like Ryan stuff
look for a new spot
no but that [__] I can't believe like
you blew my mind it blew my mind too
because I really I didn't I thought I
was gonna spend the rest of the night
just taking photos in front of houses
I'm glad I didn't have to do that I just
love how he's still talking to the
camera like this close to you describing
dude it was just so out of nowhere and I
just was like what it was like it's a
dream come true so like that being said
because you had your mind on a side
because I asked the guy for a bag and
then this oh this is exactly what was
going through my mind I asked the guy
this is very interesting stuff I asked
the guy for a bag to put our drinks in
and then he gave me the bag and I was
like okay I was I thought in my head I
was gonna put it in the bag but then he
started doing it for me and I was like
oh what a nice guy that's so nice that's
what I was thinking in my head and I
just see if I could ride it can I tell
you my my plan a that I was gonna do
when I saw you but there was no time to
do this you're gonna pants me no it was
it was gonna be infinitely worse maybe
not as bad my initial plan right when I
saw you and I saw Tiff sitting outside
yeah but I I thought it would I would
blow it if I did this much [__] but like
I was like all right smack like the plan
was I was gonna put my hoodie over my
whole like face I was gonna ask Tiff to
I was gonna lay on the sidewalk next to
her like her sitting there and with my
face like this and I was gonna go Tiff
act like I'm a homeless guy and that you
want to bring me home home to like help
me out
and then smack was gonna smack was gonna
hide in the car and film the whole thing
and I'm like I was gonna be like just
try to convince him that like we should
help him he seems like a good guy and I
was just gonna sit like this like just
hey how about this that is so good I
don't know if Tiff could carry that
through but I think I can and we should
do that to Tiff
and you see what I saw always go with
option A yeah holy [__] how do you come
up with this stuff I just you inspired
me man yeah he's very inspirational
Brian but on the on the Reel though like
the the comments about Nick being funny
that's not sarcastic everybody knows
like he's he's everyone's funniest uh
person on the panel people love him they
think he's they love your joke thank you
thank you that's really nice but like we
can't do this
I can't you know why I think because
everyone relates to Nick I think so
because he's like he's like the random
guy that got pulled into JK and then
they're like that's their dream it's
like one day I'm gonna I Wanna Be oh and
then like Nick gives them hope you know
what that's a good thing to talk about
there are a lot of people that message
JK and they go hey my dream is to be on
JK I want to get famous enough to
someday be on JK and I always tell them
it's not about being famous it's just do
you know how many unfamous people we
just have on here that we just like yeah
if it's if you're just a likable person
you're interesting and you're not gonna
kill us yeah he's not gonna kill us do
you think there's a chance and these
people could actually no because most of
them are uninteresting as [__] bro
people think they're so interesting it's
like you have not you can't even have a
conversation you just start laughing and
drooling
mostly drooling no I'm just kidding no
that would be really cool because we've
had fans on here before yeah yeah but
then like they usually have something
really interesting about them right and
like I said a lot of people think
they're interesting but they're boring
as [__]
[Music]
I mean I'm sure I feel that way yeah I'm
sure a symptom of being boring is
thinking you're really interesting
yeah if you really think about it
because he's the opposite he doesn't
think he's interesting that's the thing
but he's so interesting why am I
interesting dude huh you have the best
punch line for every setup set this guy
up give him anything set him up set him
up I won't be able to deliver not with
that pressure dude how many times you
lob me about like you lob someone up to
me and I go I don't know
and I see the look of disappointment in
your face and I'm like oh sorry I forgot
we're running a [__] show here
but see even those moments like you have
you've killed it with the best line when
you said is this good content when you
didn't know what to say that's what I
how I really honestly that's from Steve
Green a master of Comedy what about
[__] Colleen dude let's talk about
[__] I'm I'm the old you I'm feeling
I'm feeling your seat there you go you
see how she just [__] passes the buck
to me that's right because this is about
you Nick he's do you think Disney strike
you as a likable guy yeah of course
he really likes cauliflower here though
he's like a big fan you know they're
cool sometimes I think subi stays at
home doing this trying to get coffee
you'll get it bro it's more like the
status quo you know when you walk around
the mall the food everyone you could
just
can I tell you how most people look at
me they look at me like
they like squint and they go like sucks
like little kids little kids will look
at me and they'll start touching their
heart
okay I was uh they're too young it's
okay I see a kid with a [__] ice
cream just
Mom what's going on here Mom his ears
weird before Bart came to take our 7 PM
class at Lionheart there's a 6 p.m kids
class and I'm training a client and I
just happen to go get water and I was
watching the kids do Jitsu and there's
this one little kid he's newer and he
looked at me just out loud you have big
ears oh my God I was like
a little Scamp I was like yeah I do and
I was like [__] dude these kids do you
want an honest answer Ask a kid I know
is there something that's like
cauliflower ear where it's like a symbol
of oh don't mess with that guy but it's
not cauliflower is there anything else
that you could have if you have the eye
for it so Jiu Jitsu guys either have
ears or hands oh what's the hand thing
crazy calluses and their hands look like
this because from all the like grabbing
of the geek yeah most
and there's crazy calluses Judo guys
same thing
but if you have the eye for it you see
someone's hands you're like oh this
phone knows how to or somebody with like
[__] up Knuckles oh yeah like you
could probably that's the price like if
you looked at Ron's hands when he was
here his two Knuckles are literally like
this big from like 20 years of punching
yeah yeah oh that's nice scary that's
why he just knocks everybody out you
know yeah his knuckles are [__] like
huge you know you want to see a
comedian's hands it's delicate yeah baby
I have calluses from the microphone you
know
gripping it like
that do you have
Hammer up spine
um no are there any like features that
you've developed from like yeah lower
back pain oh okay good
so people go oh
the back I mean it's supposed to help
it's supposed to help assist but it
doesn't take the full weight it's not
supposed to it just balances the weight
right
um that no you the stabilizer balances
it but that's supposed to help assist
with the weight
um
but it's not supposed to take the full
amount away because you still need to be
able to so you got it at the end of the
day you're still in pain yeah good man
it's heavy huh yeah but it gets heavier
the longer you hold it how heavy is it
um well it depends on like it's like
doing what I'm rigged it's light but
then like after 10 hours man yeah
exactly like tempted for real 10 15
hours why is this my job
it depends on the setup so back to Nick
any new jokes you know
I've known you knock knock jokes
honestly I just have fun because of you
guys you guys make it a fun environment
and that's all we'll say don't you think
though yeah it's very sweet don't you
think it's fun in here especially this
is a fun job it's a fun job right yeah I
don't know anyone that would complain
about this job but people have I'll I
complain all the time but it's still a
fun job yeah it's weird it's it's so
easy I don't know I don't know we're
based on your first impression can you
imagine
complaining about what you have to do
today hell no this is fun this is coming
from a guy with every job yeah he's had
every job so this is the most credible
answer what was your first job
construction oh why does everybody in
Hawaii work construction with Russians
what Russians is there a difference
Construction Company well I was in a
citizen or anything like that but you
know I'm back in the day I'm still not
but um
the Russians in Sacramento are like I
don't I don't know you don't need papers
just [__] come work and write down
your yeah and then that was my first job
are they Russian or are they kazaki or
lithuanians
they speak Russian oh really so because
I noticed movers are all like Kazakh or
[__] Uzbek oh they have that like
Market cornered kind of dude all the all
the washing machine repair guys all
Ukrainian all the guys that have come to
my house to fix my washing machine like
the thickest Ukrainian accents ever yeah
mine's are Armenians really ah I love
that there's businesses like that that
like one it's like Vietnamese got the
nails you know Armenians have like
locksmiths dude yeah they got that
unlocked oh dude nice I didn't even see
I didn't even Armenian tow trucks have a
lot actually yeah yeah yeah yeah
they're out there trying to get jobs
they're trying to get as many jobs as a
student what about Koreans yeah korean's
got the korean's got the liquor stores
yeah that's true they got restaurants
the fake Japanese restaurant they have
the fake Japanese restaurant they got
Little Tokyo dude why is that a thing
that's great I went to Little Tokyo and
it's a Korean dude you guys want some
sushi I'm like what the [__]
uh Korean Pho too Korean food dude that
that blows my mind my mom works at a
Korean fall restaurant
she's a manager actually dude oh really
yeah and the funny thing the funniest
thing to me so Korean Sushi to me it's
like okay cool everyone loves Sushi I
get it the Korean food thing is extra
funny to me because I feel like from the
Korean perspective it's like Koreans
here Vietnamese here right yeah but then
they're like but let's make the food for
these peasants on a fake restaurant for
these guys
that's what I don't get so why why is
that you know what I mean yeah and
everyone do you know any answers oh
[__] no man no idea huh that's why
I'm asking can your mom make some bomb
fur then she does though she's like it's
like a little bit of a Korean twist into
it that's why it's good like even the
spring rolls what what makes the Korean
twist like kimchi no I don't know the
spring rolls they don't put like a bunch
of
or any of the extra stuff it's just
noodles shrimp and light with a cool
sauce so it's super simple
so you do bean sprouts with like sesame
oil I don't like bean sprouts raw but
you said you like the Wonder mermaids no
not she doesn't put it in there oh okay
it keeps it simple it's just
yeah so yeah in conclusion guys if you
had any more comments for Nick just you
can drop it in this video but uh
compliment Nick the top comment on
almost every video is something about
Nick being funny
take a pic with them that's the Easter
egg hunt I am at like a few handful of
locations and then go to every house you
could find it and try to like imagine
like what is Nick talking about a story
at this house like that
and just stand in front of the wave your
hands like 30 seconds
don't do what I did you look really
shushing they'll probably call the cops
no I think it was very Charming